johnny depp a winner with the jury and
in the court of public opinion
his fans celebrating outside as inside
the verdict was handed down the ruling
that his former wife amber heard defamed
him by describing herself as a survivor
of domestic violence
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
has mr deb proven by a greater weight of
the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard answer yes
while depp's legal team were delighted
heard listened glumly as the jury found
against her in almost every regard
ordering her to pay debt 50 million
dollars in damages
after a six-week trial it was
vindication depp's lawyers said
[Music]
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning that the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence
we are grateful so grateful to the jury
for their careful deliberation
we love you johnny
depp celebrated in newcastle where he's
on tour with the rock musician jeff beck
he thanked the jury for giving him his
life back they decided heard had wronged
him by writing this piece in the
washington post newspaper in 2018 she
describes herself as a survivor of
sexual violence the jury here has sided
with johnny depp clearly but this circus
around this particular case and the
allegations made by amber heard makes
one question if other women with similar
allegations of abuse will be deterred
from coming forward
amber heard says it will in a statement
she said i'm even more disappointed with
what this verdict means for other women
it sets back the clock to a time when
women who spoke up and spoke out could
be publicly shamed and humiliated it
sets back the idea that violence against
women is to be taken seriously
it has been a rare window into a
horribly dysfunctional hollywood
marriage with allegations of abuse on
both sides but if a winner exists in
these circumstances it is johnny depp